schools enable our kids to become who
they were meant to be
probably the most important thing that
national school choice week is trying to
accomplish is making everyone the world
in this country in particular aware that
parents need and should have the power
to determine how best to educate their
child national school choice week is a
huge event over 3,600 events all around
the country and it is schools and
advocacy groups and parent groups simply
celebrating excellence in their schools
making sure parents know you have
choices because without choice my
daughters would have failed we see in
the lives of our students every single
day the power that choice has in
transforming individual lives and
families and communities every parent
should have that ability to put try to
figure out what school what it would
what former education is better for
their child fits their child and that we
it's not one size fits all we we have a
very very ossified bureaucratic
expensive education system in this
country and while it works for a very
few for a very very great expense it
doesn't work for the disadvantaged it
doesn't work for the people in the
middle and where it does work it like I
said it cost too much well I think
anytime that there's competition it
increases the the urgency to provide a
better education freedom for parents to
make these choices it is indeed possible
I like having the option because I you'd
like to be able to take more advanced
courses and have the flexibility that
way I can place for it to do with my
friends so I love having school choice
it gets kids excited about education are
you excited for the domes brothers
tonight yes I almost got run over by two
thousand eight year olds who wanted to
see jokes brother looked very dangerous
in there very dangerous kids are so
excited and there was a lot of dancing
and it's really fun it's just a party in
the celebration for all the right
you